il leur avait fait passer un grand oral
il va maintenant les noter peut-être
même sévèrement un nicolas hulot
rappelle aux nombreux candidats à la
présidentielle des candidats qui ont
signé son pacte écologique que le
développement durable ne doit pas
disparaître de la campagne pourtant
selon lui c'est ce qui est en train de
se passer bénédicte doré
nicolas hulot nommé conseiller par josé
manuel barosso sur les questions de
climat et d'énergie voilà une
reconnaissance européenne bienvenue car
en france un mois après la signature du
pacte écologique
il semblerait que l'écologie est disparu
des programmes électoraux je suis juste
étonné que compte tenu de ce qu'ils ont
signé cette préoccupation cette
réflexion cet enjeu soit diluée au point
quasiment de disparaître dans toutes
leurs interventions publiques il ya une
forme d'incohérence kim eric
interrogations pourtant le 31 janvier
dernier droite et gauche se sont
empressés de ratifier ce fameux pacte à
l'époque nicolas hulot était crédité de
12% des votes devant ségolène royal par
la d'engagement à l'excellence
environnementale
nicolas sarkozy a même réclamé un g20 du
climat mais depuis plus 20 mo d'où la
colère de nicolas hulot colère aussi des
candidats écolos qui l'accusent de
décrédibiliser l'écologie la conséquence
de ce qu'il a fait en faisant signer à
tout le monde quelque chose de très
light c'est de tuer carrément l'écologie
politique en france et avec cette
attitude de surcroît de relatif mépris à
l'égard des candidats qui défendent
l'environnement depuis 25 ans comme moi
même eh bien il a accrédité l'idée que
finalement seuls comptaient les grands
partis mais les grands partis se foutent
de l'environnement on le savait avant et
on le sait après fait que les états
majors des partis est considéré qu'ils
étaient quittes avec ce sujet qui peut
passer à autre chose et c'est à dire
tour à tour d'autres clientèles qui leur
demandait le contraire des engagements
qu'ils avaient pris ne me paraît pas
dans le bon sens les candidats
signataires ont encore quelques semaines
pour rectifier le tiers d'ici là
l'animateur de télévision reviendra sur
le terrain au moins médiatique il a
convoqué les associations écologiques un
grand rassemblement parisien le 1er
avril